مرحبًا ، أنا دكتور سانجاي جوبتا ، مضيف
بودكاست Chasing Life على قناة CNN ،
البحث هو أن تدريب القوة الواضح
يساعد على بناء أجسام أكثر صحة
وتحسين قدرتك على الحركة ، ولكن إليك
الشيء الذي يبدأ به معظم الناس في إهمال
تدريب القوة مع مرور الوقت ، بينما في
الواقع ربما يكون أكثر أهمية  مع تقدمك في
العمر ، هذا هو السبب في أن
كتلة عضلاتك تميل إلى الذروة في
سن الثلاثين أو نحو ذلك ، ولكن بعد ذلك عليك حقًا
العمل على ذلك ، فهذا يعني أن
قوة المرأة تميل حقًا إلى الانخفاض
بعد سن 65 بالنسبة للرجال في سن 70 تقريبًا.
ووجدت إحدى الدراسات القوية أن تدريب القوة
كان مرتبطًا بانخفاض خطر
الموت المبكر يعتقد الباحثون أن أحد
الأسباب هو أن جسمك يحتوي على الكثير من
الدهون التي تزيد من خطر الإصابة
بأمراض القلب والأوعية الدموية حتى بعض أنواع السرطان ،
لذلك يجب أن تهدف إلى رفع الأثقال على
الأقل.  مرتين في الأسبوع بغض النظر عن عمرك ،
سيؤدي ذلك إلى تقوية عضلاتك
ومنع فقدان العظام وتحسين خفة الحركة ،
أو يمكنك وضع بعض
الأوزان والمشي فقط
كخيار آخر باستخدام أشرطة المقاومة وممارسة
التمارين التي تستخدم وزن جسمك
لتقوية عضلاتك  يمكنك سماع
المزيد حول كيفية تحسين صحتك
وحياة Chase أينما حصلت على
ملفاتك الصوتية